حمله الاعتقالات الامنيه والملاحقات
القضائيه استهدفت رئيس الحزب الجمهوريه
عصام الشابي والقياديه البارزه في جبهه
الخلاص الوطني شيماء عيسى لتتسع القائمه
التي ضمت سياسيين وحقوقيين ومحامينا
ونقابيين ملاحقات اعتبرتها المعارضه تصفيه
حساب من الرئيس قيس سعيد مع خصومه
السياسيين ومنتقديه من جميع الاطياف
المدنيه والنقابيه
كل هذه الحمله تستهدف قوى الديمقراطيه
القوات المناهضه للانقلاب القوى اللي قالت
لقيس سعيد لا للحكم الفردي لا للاستبداد
ولا للعوده لما قبل الثوره لكن الرئيس قيس
سعيد يؤكد ان الايقافات تاتي على خلفيه
تامر المعتقلين على امن الدوله الداخلي
والخارجي وانها تتم دون انتهاك للحقوق
والحريات مع الحرص على استقلاليه القضاء
هي حرب تحرير وطني ولابد من تحري وطن من
كل هؤلاء الادرار
الشعب التونسي الى الوراء ونحن نحن
الامانه في حين هم ياكلوا في الواقع كامل
الفكر الاجرامي لتحطيم الدوله ولضرب الوطن
وفي ظل ما تشهده البلاد تطار اسئله حول
حظوظ نجاح اي مبادره لحوار وطني ينزع فتيل
الازمه او يخفف حاله الاحتقان لا يوجد
حوار الحوار المطلوب هو حوار يجمع المجتمع
التونسي مع بعضه البعض بكل مكونات وقوات
سياسيه والحيه والمجتمعيه حول اي تونس
نريد هل هي تونس العنصريه القمعيه التي
تعود بنا الى قرون ماضيه حيث يحكم الملك
ونحن نطيع هي تونس تنهض من رمادها وتؤسس
لدوله دوله القانون والحريات حرب تقرير
الوطني كما يصفها سعيد جبهت بانتقادات
داخليه وخارجيه والخيط الناظم بين هذه
التفاعلات التعبير عن القلق والانشغال
والدعوه الى الحوار سدب عليك الجزيره تونس